prop 24 passed california
thank you for looking out for our data
and privacy rights
yang speaks is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights
visit expressvpn.com
[Music]
[Applause]
i do not want the sleeping giants
andrew to ever go back to sleep i want
them to stay awake
i want them to continue to fight for
what is just for what is right
and what for what is good to not allow a
biden harris administration to have a
honeymoon
because the pandemic just revealed what
was already there and like you just said
that
populist energy on the trump side is
going to go somewhere
and it's going to go to somebody that's
a little more savvy than
uh president donald j trump you could
have someone
both malignant and competent you know
what i mean like not not just like
like the kind of buffoonery uh of
uh it would be worth trump it would be
worse so it will behoove
the democratic party to get a clue and
to get a clue
quickly and to provide a to have a
vision that provides provision
for the people and that's why i love
about your universe universal basic
income you you came in with some really
strong ideas and i think
um between your campaign and our
campaign we were quite
a force in awakening the sleeping giants
and getting people to dream another
dream
a bigger dream to see the world through
new eyes or through a different lens of
what is possible
[Music]
zack new president elect
joe biden yes
man the trump era is over the national
global nightmare did you see that that
uh like people were celebrating around
the world i guess it makes sense
but like people people are like dancing
in the streets all over the world
new york was pretty cool uh the liberals
are having a field day and the urban
cities in particular
going nuts um
wild it's amazing to see how are you
feeling man
i feel great you know it was hysterical
someone told me on fox they referred to
those uh celebrations as protesters
that's that's that makes sense that
checks out
it's pretty hysterical it's like look at
the protest by just freaking
dancing in the streets mostly peaceful
protests celebrating
[Laughter]
yeah wow um
it's it was kind of cool to see all the
global leaders like chime in including
israel like netanyahu
um was very very glowing of his
relationship with joe biden it's
interesting
well i mean heck joe's the new president
time to get in on that action
[Laughter]
i i genuinely am concerned about
what's going on in the trump white house
right now um
because uh imagine being him and just
hearing everyone like chanting and
singing
outside outside of the white house 24 7.
uh and the alternate reality that you
have
uh is shrinking very fast like
collapsing on you like even the people
around you are just like looking around
being like what you know what what do i
do
um i i i'm really concerned about what
happens over the next two months because
like i feel like we could see trump
really degenerate
uh which you know it's hard to imagine
what he could do that's
worse or deteriorate but i'm genuinely
concerned about his
state of being because
for someone who thrives on positive
adulation
so much like feeling like your
uh universally uh a mocked or being a
loser or whatnot
and then have to actually kind of put on
a brave face for two months or one like
the whole thing is bizarre
um you know like most human beings in
that situation would just be like
and i'm out i'm gonna like curl up in
bed and like you know let the world
forget about me for a minute but that's
obviously not an option for him
uh it's gonna be it's gonna be delicate
um you know i'm i'm genuinely concerned
about it
so he is as of this point president
trump um we're recording this sunday
afternoon um you're getting this monday
november 9th
at this point donald trump has not
conceded the election in fact he has
said publicly he's going to fight it
because he believes he won
and won by a lot to use his words um
to me it does not appear um every
network has called the race it does not
appear that there's any wild wide scale
or any sort of scale
voter fraud or shenanigans there is you
know there's probably some
things on the margins as always he lost
like 10 ways from sideways
[Laughter]
it was closer than we all thought by a
lot closer we all thought but it was a
pretty
decisive win i mean he flipped four
possibly five states um from 2016.
well well this is the tough part zach
it's like and and i i do
get upset when people talk about it as
if it was a slam dunk victory it was a
slam dunk victory if you eventually
count the different
uh electoral votes in the pads four days
later five days later you know what i
mean
like like and that helps a great deal
where like you don't need pa necessarily
if you get arizona nevada you know you
don't need
any of it if you get georgia so like
that that feels great
thank goodness thank you everyone who
voted for joe all over the country
um that said this was much much more
tightly contested than it should have
been
and it was a massive crushing
disappointment
for democrats if they are at all honest
if you'd lined up house leadership and
said hey
how are you gonna fare in the house no
one would have said oh we're gonna lose
like six seven incumbent races we're
gonna lose absolute uh races they were
counting on wins they were trying to
expand them out
growing yeah and and uh we supported
many candidates in places that were
trying to go purple uh you know in texas
and
nebraska and iowa and people like
our candidates essentially got washed
out by a rising trump tide
in many of these states
and again if you lined up house
leadership
prior to election day they would
have been i'm sure but cocky about how
many seats they were going to gain
none of them would have said we're going
to lose seeds none of them would would
have said we're going to lose
uh seven of our current members
it was and so you
talked about this on cnn um and it was
in my opinion
your best moment in a long time you
gotta you guys can go good moments on
there oh so me no kidding
possibly i meant it with love um but um
but you said um you said basically the
the democrats a lot of work to do
um and that a feeling we felt was that
when we went and said you're a democrat
people look at you like you had a
you know another head grown out of you
um and that
the democrats seem to have spent too
much time policing a lot of cultural
issues instead of fighting and making
lives better for the working class in
particular
um i know it's not a tweet but it is
kind of a sound bite on the show i'd
love your thoughts on i thought it was
powerful
there were so many people that came out
in support of that uh
across the political spectrum thought
care to elaborate on what you mean but i
know exactly what you mean but for those
are listening um
like where did that come from for you
and um where do you think we go from
here
frankly as a party as a country well it
came from direct experience because
we spent so much time in iowa talking to
uh people just at like the general store
or the
the diner the um hardware store
the you know like you name it the farm
uh
and the democratic party did not seem
like
their friend to a lot of these people
and then you would be like wow you know
and so
as someone running for president uh
under uh
that that party it was jarring where
it's like why are you
so turned off by the democratic party
that should
theoretically be your friend um and
it was because they did not feel like
the democratic party was
fighting for them or speaking for them
it seemed if anything to many of them
that the democratic party was talking at
them
and this is something that you should
like yeah
and there's something really fundamental
about this like this this actually makes
me angry and sad
some to some extent is that democrats
will look up and say hey we won
and we did win thank goodness you know
like you and i fought very hard to try
and help like hallelujah but
what were the quintessential
battleground states four
eight years ago ohio and iowa
and ohio went red significantly
last time like eight points um and
despite the fact that the blind campaign
tried to flip it like i think joe showed
up there in like the last
day or two of the campaign um it
it stayed red and it was not like that
that tight
um which made me sad like i thought that
we might do better in iowa frankly
um same with iowa where iowa used to be
quintessential purple state it's like
the first caucus state for a reason
you don't put your first caucus in a
state that's frankly like really
like very red or very blue i think you
put it in a battleground
uh obama won iowa trump wins
iowa by nine points in 2016
uh and this is where we were campaigning
like and and trump won iowa cleanly
again this time
our friend j.d scholten lost despite
running a great race
abby finkenauer who was a democratic
member of congress in iowa lost her
race so for the democratic party you're
like wait
ohio represents the industrial midwest
and you're losing them
uh iowa loses represents the
agricultural midwest and you're losing
them
and then the democratic party's response
could be like it's all right
we're getting arizona we're getting
georgia we're getting places where there
are demographic changes
uh and and that's like i mean again
thrilled
to to um to be bringing in
president-elect joe biden
but like if you just
give up essentially on being competitive
in places like ohio and iowa then you
do actually end up um defining yourself
increasingly
as a party that represents um
other parts of the country that are not
the midwest or not
uh in like places that that are not
frankly that diverse
uh and that gins up polarization all the
more
where you look up and say well now my
priorities are not
uh fighting for farmers fighting for
factory workers fighting for that stuff
uh you know now my priorities are gonna
be
like the growing urban centers and like
the places where people are moving
and and you know it that's possibly
an electoral winning strategy but i'm
going to say that is a losing strategy
for
our country if that is the plan because
then you just
end up increasing polarization rather
than decreasing it
if you're the party your incentives are
not actually the same as the countries
it's like if the democratic party's like
well no skin off my back i can still win
um i'll just win in another way um and
like no one pays
a price for that but you know who does
pay a price for that all of us
but also the democrats in ohio and iowa
like i'm friends with jd and the fact
that jd
campaigned his ass off and then lost not
competitively
breaks my heart jd was great jd raised a
lot of money
like he did everything in his in his
power uh
and and he he got wrecked
in part because of this phenomenon that
uh that i'm talking about
[Music]
i'm 32 and if i have like one beer
or even like a late night i just get
dehydrated faster i've started using
liquid iv since i started sponsoring
this podcast and i love it one serving
of liquid iv provides the same hydration
as drinking two to three bottles of
water alone
it is it's super simple you just it's
like a crystal light package you rip it
off
pour it in some water and they have a
ton of cool flavors they've got sweet
and juicy guava
crisp watermelon and then apple pie and
it's got five essential vitamins more
vitamin c than an
orange and as much potassium as a banana
so it's healthier than your sugary
sports drinks
no artificial flavors or preservatives
and less sugar than an apple so it's
pretty
really good for you um and it's made
with clean ingredients so no gm
non-gmo vegan and free of gluten dairy
and soy so whatever diet you're on
this will fit i'm a big fan of liquid iv
if you want the benefits you want to
hydrate faster and more efficiently
liquid iv
is for you this stuff works it's
available nationwide in walmart
the beverage section you can get 25 off
when you go to liquid
iv.com and use code yang at checkout
that's 25 off anything you order when
you use promo code yang at liquidity.com
get better hydration today at
liquidity.com promo code yang
[Music]
joe biden right now and kamala harris
have and they gave their victory speech
talking about we need to unify the
country and there they had it kind of
when they're running but now it's a big
time we
we want to be the president of all
americans not just red americans or blue
americans
um i think those are words that sound
nice um i think in reality
in my opinion and you could argue this
is fact that the democrats were not very
unifying
when the donald was in charge you know
now now trump has his own
you know various forms of divisiveness
but the dems were not like lining up to
to um to be best friends with with the
republicans right
unfortunately trump enhanced
polarization because if trump's like hey
like uh you know i'm like a raging
extremist and then you're like let's get
along like that you know
right so i'm not putting it on dems at
all um but i do think there's probably
some guilt on both sides but
my question is like if you if you're joe
both how do you start to bring the
country together
in your kind of first your first
initiatives and
uh legislative actions in the first
hundred days or so but also
you know if you were him how do you
steer the party because i think joe is
actually more aligned with where you are
at least like theoretically right in
terms of your conversation with him like
what what do you think
um how do you implant this in the
democratic leadership
um going forward i thought joe gave it a
a tremendous speech
last night uh he gave me gave me chills
like the
the um end was maybe the
best joe biden speech i've ever seen uh
it and it was incredible that
you know you have that kind of moment
where you know you're going to be the
president you're trying to bring the
country together
and you're channeling something bigger
than yourself i was so happy for
us all but happy for joe
and kamala in particular because you
know you could
sense that they embraced and embodied
the magnitude of the occasion in the
moment
uh so i think joe's definitely going to
be
very very unifying um in terms of
message
in terms of um getting
trying to uh heal really
um you know he's he's naturally
someone who wants to
work with different types of folks he's
not someone who's like oh you're not
someone that you know i want to deal
with
uh so that's very positive um the
problem right now is that mitch
mcconnell
does not seem to be reciprocating where
like some of the early noises out of
mitch were
oh i'm not going to appoint any
cabinet secretaries unless they meet
with our stringent
you know conservative approval and then
even lindsey graham
was like joe deserves a cabinet like
even i don't really like i think ram
sounds reasonable
yeah whereas like come on [ __ ] like we
should at least let joe like appoint
some people uh
so so this is already heading down a
very rough path which is why we are
heading to georgia
because if joe says great things
and then can't get anything done we are
not making progress really
and the 70 plus million folks who voted
for trump
like that to me is the most clear
sign that things are not really going
well
uh in terms of most communities around
the country
uh you know i i frankly expected uh joe
to win by more because
i thought that many of the folks who
voted for trump that i talked to
uh changed their mind we're like this is
not the guy
um but then trump found new voters you
know
like a lot of new voters five million
more trump voters
so imagine being someone who sat out
trump 2016
and then saw everything's going on and
be like ooh yeah like turns out that
like that's what i wanted all along um
so we're
we're running out of time to
genuinely bring the country together and
it's going to be nearly impossible with
mitch mcconnell saying no to
everything and being an obstructionist
which he seems like he's
already suggesting he's going to be uh
so
you me the yang gang my family everyone
we're heading to georgia
let's go it's gonna be great uh we're
gonna go fight it out
in georgia until january 5th uh for the
two senate races that are there so if
you don't understand why we're heading
to georgia
um right now it's going to be 48.50 in
the senate with mitch as the majority
leader but there are two
special senate races on january 5th that
if they're very competitive both of them
and that if dems win them both then
you're 50 50 in the senate and then
kamala becomes the tiebreaker
then all of a sudden uh joe's ability to
pass cash relief
uh joe's ability to uh
try to work on infrastructure joe's
ability to get things done
shoots up tremendously because you don't
have mitch mcconnell
carping about uh uh you know how
this uh is too ambitious or this is too
um expensive or whatever like the the
objection is going to be i mean heck
like mitch isn't motivated by principle
we saw with obama it's like you he
wasn't like oh i'm gonna do
i'm gonna say no no no and then i'll say
yes to this he just says no
so we need to give our government a
chance to operate
and folks who listen to this podcast
know that
you know like washington has problems
operating you know it's not
it's not operating at a high level right
now it's it's very very dysfunctional
uh and so if we can give it a modicum of
functionality it could be enormous
for millions of families around the
country and the lever is georgia
so georgia it's going to be neck and
neck every vote's going to count
so if we get hundreds thousands of
volunteers
to head to georgia and canvas and knock
on doors very very safely obviously you
know
wear masks and stay away from people and
do outdoor events and the rest of it
um and activate the folks in georgia
it's going to be an uphill climb
i looked at it there was a special
election in georgia that
um apparently most of the special
elections skew conservative at least
historically
um but i but i think this one will be
different
if we execute like if all of the folks
who
wanted joe to win uh help in georgia
that because the fact is joe's agenda is
going to
get stalled uh if he can't get anything
through the senate
so celebrate joe's victory yes but in
practical terms
uh this these two georgia races
uh are going to define whether joe can
get things done or not
uh so it's imperative we can we get to
georgia and
um activate voters if we activate enough
democratic voters clearly there's a path
to victory because
the entire state just flipped blue and
both of these senate races were very
very competitive like you know one or
two points in
assault's case um and uh
uh raphael warnock it's unclear because
it was a jungle primary but he did get
more votes than any other candidate so
that's a great place to start
um so so uh but it's gonna be
this is not a slime dog at all it's one
reason why we need all hands on deck
kelly lefler who's the other
who's technically the incumbent so if
you
remember the senators who are accused of
insider trading when uh covet news hit
she's one of them she's also the
richest senator in the in
in the country which is really saying
something because a lot of rich senators
um but she's worth uh she really she's
worth 520 million dollars
um and so she's going to spend a lot in
the you know like the conservatives are
going to spend a lot of money
um so uh she also this is just for the
hoops people out there because you know
i love hoops
she also is the owner of the wnba team
um in atlanta the atlanta dream and when
the wnba had the black lives matter
messaging she like was the only person
who was like this is not right
and then all of her players were like
sell the team you know because all of
her players are obviously
like yeah most of them are black and you
know obviously you know like
don't want an owner who's somehow
uh you know um
like uh heading in the opposite
direction um so
it it's pretty fascinating what's at
stake
uh so i can't wait to get to georgia i
think everyone who
campaigned for joe should join us in
georgia because
we need to give joe a chance to get
things done so if you are thinking of
coming with us to georgia we're going to
have some information soon it's going to
be a blast
it's going to be like an iowa reunion
but warmer
and it's actually even kind of the same
time of year like january instead of
february
but it's going to be great we're going
to have
so much fun events housing all of these
incredible yang gang
volunteers have already started offering
rooms and bedrooms and
housing for folks this is the future of
our country on the line i can't wait to
fight it out with a lot of you uh
there's just so much love
um from the yang yang and from iowa it's
like the best
time of my life in many ways and then
when emily got out there too she was
like this is it you know just
sharing in the warmth and the love um uh
you know lacey's there
in in atlanta we've got like a lot of
friends in atlanta there's atlanta yang
gang shout out to you all you guys are
incredible
uh so we're coming your way georgia like
freaking
yangapalooza 2020
maybe we'll even have something 20
21-ish there are all these people that
are already saying that they're coming
i don't want to like put them on the
hook uh but
let's just say that some of the people
you associate with the yang gang
have said that actually screw it i'll
talk about this stuff why not
i'll put the heat on them why not so i
was at uh i was at snl
uh last night uh courtesy of dave um
chappelle obviously was hosting you
should watch that monologue if you have
not it was
genius as always um so then dave
uh so then dave and i were talking and i
was like hey we're heading to georgia
and he was like man
like uh you know if you need a hand uh
you know would love to help so
dave may be coming to georgia uh
and uh helping um
helping us win those those races there's
some other heavyweight folks that
uh have said to me that they're looking
at coming
bands um like
it's gonna be wild i mean again all it's
gonna be outdoors uh
like michelle wolf said she'll come and
do an event
um so that'll be something that'll be
probably again outdoors
one thing i love about comedians is like
all you need to do is give them an
audience and
like uh um um but we're gonna have
a blast it's going to be yangapalooza
we're going to go to georgia
um knock on doors in a socially safe way
we're going to like get folks out um
the timeline is tight like the early
voting starts
pretty soon i want to say
i want i i should check the dates here
but um i want the
voter registration deadlines december
7th i know that one
um and early voting starts pretty
quickly
i think um sometime later this month uh
so
it's going to be epic
come with us to georgia we're going to
have soon resources available
uh where people can sign up get
activated
get housing uh and plug in in a way
that's
effective because you know if we're
gonna do this obviously we need to be
roped in with the
campaigns uh and have uh effective
canvassing lists and the rest of it
um but that it's gonna be awesome it
really is the future of our country on
the line
if we win we win these races then we
have a chance to solve some of the big
problems including again cash relief
everyone knows i'm
i'm all about cash relief cash relief
cash relief like
i think we've got a much better chance
of getting cash relief out the door if
you have
uh if you have a unified government and
people uh
actually willing to sign bills into law
um so
this to me is like a lever where we
could potentially alleviate the
suffering of millions and millions of
people
i mean tell me that isn't worth it like
you know you want to go fight for good
but you know this is the battleground
until january 5th and the votes come in
i i love this
this plan and vision injury so we're
going to georgia and it's
to me it's very andrew yang because it's
um
one it's forward thinking and it's
problem-solving in the sense that
right now everybody's doing their you
know spiking the football because we won
the election which is true but you're
seeing this clear as day like
the entire political world is going to
come crashing down on georgia
like whoever wins these two senate seats
will hold the power in the in congress
in the united states
um and you as a problem solver you
always are and very logical like
and the best thing to do is if you care
about the country is go down there and
freaking help
so that's we're gonna do um and so more
details to come
um and look we wanna be mindful and
thoughtful to those campaigns
on the ground there that have a lot of
great things going we wanna be additive
and not
you know oh yeah we're gonna coordinate
with them we're not gonna map it up
like you know we're just going to plug
folks and resources into the last thing
we need the awesome campaign
you know so don't worry you know so
we're getting organized
super excited about it um but there's a
lot of energy around it
i think we're going to be able to help a
great deal i i generally think we're
vital because
uh a lot of like you have to keep in
mind a lot of folks
uh in georgia like you know are just
going back to their lives like joe won
you know like oh there's some races
going on like they might not understand
the enormity of it
um and and certainly like if someone
were to tell you hey there's a special
election january 5th you'd be like what
like i vote november i just voted like
what's going on you know
uh so oh my gosh so yeah i
i think uh i think our job is incredibly
important where we have to keep people
engaged and activated and uh keep
these races right at the forefront of
the democratic
voters in georgia's mind so they see it
as as big a deal as they should
right and i want to say this to be clear
because
you're going to laugh at this um but
we're not moving there
to vote ourselves and we're not
recommending people like pretend to get
residency in georgia
and vote we are moving there to help
people live in georgia
vote for their senator um because i had
apparently republicans
uh texting me i'm not like republican
friends like operatives texting me that
isn't yang moving there to
to to establish residency and through
the vote that's voter fraud i'm like
that is a ridiculous statement that's
not what's happening we are
there to help others who live there
already you're not moving there to vote
yourself andrew
can we put that on the record for now
yeah i don't even know what the
those rules look like like i'm going to
rally folks
uh it it's laughable but it seriously
was my morning i want to quickly end on
this note um
and because i think you have an
interesting voice here um
there's going to be a lot of hoopla from
our president
and possibly some republicans about
voter fraud
in this election and i think you have a
trusted voice here because i think if
democrats were doing shenanigans you
would
be one of the first democrats to to call
them out and be honest about it um
there's been no evidence of any voter
tampering there obviously like
all of the accounting firms you can see
they're freaking like you know just
rooms full of people counting votes and
then there are dozens of
democratic and republican observers just
hanging out in the room
being bored out of their minds
[Laughter]
well that's what trump is doing they're
sending like a person to the election
you know
council elections wherever it is that
the location and they're like we're not
able to get in he's like yeah
we already have a democrat and
republican been trained to identify
like you're already in it's like one
thing you want
yeah you're already there just chill out
and the incentives here are so like
they cut the other way if you're a
republican secretary of state you want a
fair election
this stuff it does make me mad because
uh it's literally like what are you
objecting to
uh you know and uh and the the uh
objections
um you know are clearly just
uh malleable based upon what you think
is gonna help your guy win
and it's cool you know like we we each
want our person to win
um but we still need to have some
grounding in objective
uh vote counts and reality
and uh and this is one of the most
dangerous things that that we're going
to be fighting against more and more
this actually is to me one of the great
missions we have
uh is that uh people just don't trust
anything
anymore uh because our institutions have
been failing us in various ways
uh you know like you look at the media
and the media like trust us we know the
media
does get stuff wrong and everyone has a
very distorting lens
and and so you you look at it and uh if
you're a discerning person you're like
oh i can't believe any of this stuff and
that's where we pushed millions of
americans but it's very very dangerous
i'm happy to say that um
that the vast majority of folks on this
one republican democrat doesn't matter
looking up being like look
like you know there was no widespread
voter fraud that
caused this result i mean it does not
make any sense on the face of it
uh it was just all over the place there
are people in these things like that the
stakes are
like you said way way too high and even
the examples that they come up with
um are dumb you know it's like oh they
erected a
cardboard barrier so we couldn't see
it's like well there are a dozen
freaking observers
in the room already and you're making
them nervous because there's a crowd of
you like freaking shaking your fists at
ordinary americans just trying to count
votes
it's like
but like uh you know i mean if i was the
manager that situation i'd be like maybe
we should like just
like put up a curtain which is
essentially what they did um and there's
nothing nefarious going on
the whole thing yeah it pains it it
pains me and it's going to be a real
problem because
uh these these conspiracy theories are
just getting stronger
frankly and and more and more people are
becoming receptive to them for a variety
of reasons
it's um it's
it hurts democracy right and this is
like the one institution that we can't
have fail
you know we've had a whole bunch fail
we've got a whole bunch lose trust but
this is the one our votes and i i do
applaud there's a number of republicans
that have said
look it's over like shut up you know and
i applaud them that's that's to me
true patriotism um because and democrats
you know
what's the baseline zach in in past
times yes we just agree with that
like like they're all just freaking
crazy anyone who did not do that
uh like um needs to
get their mic removed essentially like
over the sense that like like we should
stop
trusting them if they're like this thing
is rigged
oh like you know like the rest of it's
like based on
like you know based upon your desire for
it to be rigged
like based on the fact you lost
you know certainly again if you got a
big microphone or megaphone like you
know
you should have a little bit more
discipline and something
this important you know cause like if
you have people just
don't trust this vote count it's
corrosive
so look to recap joe biden is our
president
um we've got a lot of work to do as a
party
and to start with that work we're
heading to georgia we're going to
register and get out the vote as much as
humanly possible
um andrew's moving register other people
[Laughter]
yes not ourselves oh my gosh um
and today we've got um we've got a good
guess we did this before the election so
we don't talk about the election with
her but nina turner is joining
uh powerhouse nina turner the freaking
former head of our
revolution national co-chair for the
bernie sanders campaign
we got to know her on the trail i'm such
a fan of herzen admirer she's like a
true fighter for the people based in
ohio too which we talked about a little
bit
uh really grateful to to nina for uh
sharing
some of her time with us uh and sharing
some of her
hopes for the democratic party and the
future
uh she's gonna be fighting for folks
tirelessly
um she's a real warrior that's the
that's the term i think of when
i think of nina turner just a true
warrior
uh like just love her yeah and it's
timely because
we're talking about you know bernie's
vision for it was a little different
than yours but they were he was talking
about we need to talk
we need to focus on the working class
right that is that is the core of
our revolution of core of what bernie's
doing and so um
timely topic given the election uh you
guys can enjoy it
nina turner joining yang speaks
here at yang speaks we are all about our
data
and privacy rights what the heck has
gone on where we get sold and resold for
tens of billions of dollars a year
california just passed prop 24 that
protects
their data rights you're not going to
believe this california now is going to
have a digital
protection agency where they have like
privacy cops like
jean-claude van damme in that movie time
cop like privacy cops
who go around telling the tech companies
hey don't do this with our data
because it's our data thank you
california let's have other states
around the country pass the same
type of laws but while we're waiting for
these laws to sweep the country how do
we protect our individual data so people
don't see everything we do
expressvpn is the answer it reroutes
your internet connection through
their servers so no one can see what
you're doing you're like a secret agent
but still you but sort of secret
expressvpn has been named
the number one vpn in the world by cnet
and wired major companies use it yang
speaks recommends it
stop letting people keep logs of what
you do online visit expressvpn.com
yang right now and find out how you can
get three months free that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s
vpn.com yang if you're like me
and you're thinking about vpn you're
like okay well now that i'm routing my
data through vpn
doesn't that mean the vpn can see what
i'm doing and they get my data instead
and it's just creating the same problem
um and you're right to think that but
that's it and a lot of vpns claim to
have a no logs policy
but a lot have been caught logging
customer activity but expressvpn is the
only vpn we trust
because they use trusted server
technology so their first major vpn
provider to engineer that all their vpn
servers run in ram which makes it
impossible
for their vpn servers to store any data
including logs of
any expressvpn customer so you don't
have to take my word for it or express
vbn's word for it they're so confident
in their no logs claim that they even
had one of the biggest assurance firms
pricewaterhousecoopers pwc
has audited this crap so it is worth it
they don't track your stuff at all it's
completely private
so expressvpn.com slash yang get three
months free
[Music]
[Applause]
it is my privilege and pleasure to
welcome to yank speaks
the co-chair of the bernie 2020 campaign
history professor extraordinaire
activist
leader of the revolution nina turner
welcome nina how are you
oh andrew yang it's such a pleasure to
be with you i thought you was gonna say
leader of the free world
you know you was on the road there a
little bit
oh you know i mean shoot if you were the
leader of the free world it'd be a
massive upgrade over this nonsense we're
dealing with right now
absolutely it definitely would be but no
it's such a pleasure to join you
as we were talking earlier before we
started our interview about our
mutual admiration for each other and
it's certainly an honor to join you on
your show
yeah seeing you on the trail i was like
that was nina turner that was awesome
and
it is it was fun too because like you
said when you're on the trail you kind
of run across various people
um and um like some people you like some
people you like less
that's right that's true and it's all
good but you
and your team especially were always
courteous
that was my experience and there are a
lot of people in uh bernie world or in
the revolution
who absolutely admire you and and the
work that you have done and what you are
doing and i'm certainly one of those
people
oh thank you nina that means so much to
me because i was a burner in 2016.
i still get the text to prove it i was
getting texts on the regular which is
like you know i've just wanted like um
you know one of uh bernie's donors
um uh and i gotta say
um when we were on the trail i didn't
know if bernie liked me and it was i was
very nervous about it but then he said
to an interviewer it's like oh i like
andrew gang and i was like really he
likes me i was like so happy
um and so hanging out with him i saw
jane on the trail too
um and i was so thrilled that it seemed
like they knew where i was coming from
and that um we were tackling some of the
same problems from slightly different
angles or perspectives but it really was
in my mind always super aligned
and when folks said to me like hey i'm
for bernie or whatever it's like yeah i
was for bernie last time too like don't
worry about it
that's right no i i've definitely heard
the senator
uh mention you in in the fondest of ways
and you know he's not a
he's not a touchy philly kind of guy so
when he says he likes somebody
you can take that to the bank believe it
when he says that so
yeah i'm glad yeah i i believed it it
really
like i felt elevated in that moment and
then when i saw him next too like i i
felt the same
um so i'm gonna be selfish or a little
bit selfish
um but first i think people who might
not be familiar with your story
um you know you went through a lot of
adversity when you're young
you're in cleveland right now um which
is
the area you grew up in you kind of rose
through the political ranks you're a
city council person you're a state
legislator
and then you hit the national stage in
uh on bernie's first run and the thing
that i'm going to be selfish about first
would love to hear from you what you
what your experience was like coming up
um which must not have been easy i know
you were one of um
one of seven like the oldest of seven
children
well that part i did not know tell me
more oh this of seven children
and you have my my bio just right
i ran for secretary of state though in
2014 so before i got to 2016 i was the
democratic nominee
in my home state of ohio to run against
one of the worst
secretary of states in the country at
that time
obviously a republican i hate to say
that they've done everything
possible to try to suppress the vote
over the
since the presidency of president obama
we saw a surge
in republican secretary of state
governors legislators legislatures
doing things that are the antithesis to
our democracy so
yeah i ran for statewide office in the
great state of ohio is quite an
experience we have 88 counties and i
tried to get to all 88 of those counties
and all i wanted to do yang was to
expand and protect
access to the ballot box just
old-fashioned just think people should
have the right to vote
no matter who they want to vote for that
really shaped me i mean that was a
really big deal ohio is a big state
and i learned so much especially
traveling in the rural areas i'm a city
girl i'm from cleveland ohio
and although i necessarily i didn't win
that race what i did
when was new perspective and also
you know you know building up my
political bona fides and it was
absolutely the right thing to do i
actually for
i we have term limits in ohio and i
could have i could have ran one more
time
for the senate but i sacrificed that run
to take it to the
the republicans good for you
because that role in ohio is so crucial
not just for the people of ohio but i
mean that can have national
ramifications uh and i can and i can
imagine
what that campaign looked like um
because i campaigned in the rural
midwest
i campaigned in the urban midwest uh
then
and you learn a lot you know you head
out to places
uh that you might not have been
otherwise and you have to make the case
like look i'm actually here to try and
help
there's you know and and but but there
were some
uh bridges to cross and some barriers to
overcome at least in my experience
oh yeah i mean as i'm sure you know and
you're
a person of color too and i am an
african-american woman just in case
people didn't know that
it's a struggle and running for
statewide office also opened my eyes to
the negative side which is
very few african-americans not just in
my state
have have ran and or won
statewide office and we got to do
something about that in the united
states of america is really sad
uh black women there has not been a
black woman governor
yet in the united states we got to do
something about that
really even yeah really and even when we
get our first
is not enough and you know state our
sister steve abrams ran
very hard in georgia and all almost had
it
we all not maybe not everybody but
certain of us believe that she was
robbed
but it says something about this country
and although we've come
a long way we have a longer way to go
in that it is still so incredibly hard
for african americans and other people
of color to penetrate
when they are running for statewide
office and as
you and i both know those statewide
offices are
actually a lifting point or launching
pad if you will
to a national office as a nation
we have a long way to go to reconcile in
many industries
and politics is one of those whether or
not we truly believe
that every citizen no matter where they
came from no matter where their
ancestors came from
whether or not they are
i even hate i mean when i think about
black people the word word becomes the
mind because we fought so hard to be
respected but there is a golf
in this country when it comes to certain
levels of office and higher
levels from state level all the way up
to the federal level is one that is
still
quite a challenge the the u.s senate and
the presidency
and governor's offices well you're
literally
a teacher of history uh and i love the
fact that you were pushing hard at that
envelope um i'm pretty sure when you
were
a state legislator uh there probably
weren't that many black state
legislators and
you would be right and isn't that but
it's sad though when you when you stop
to think about if we just keep going you
just kind of say oh we got to work on
that
but if you really just stop and pause to
think about
that it is it is sad it is a sad
commentary on this nation and we got
we have a lot of work to do in many
areas but no there were not many
of us
yang gang the holidays are around the
corner
that means if you're a good person
you're going to be mailing stuff
mailing involves postage in the post
office who wants to deal with that
not me why don't you use stamps.com it
brings
the postal service and the up
the power of ups it's like a superhero
team up between the usps
and ups to your computer use stamps.com
and you can print postage you can do
everything you can do at a post office
from your own home saving you time and
money small businesses use this up the
wazoo we used
stamps.com on the campaign ourselves so
don't spend a minute of your holiday
season at a post office
sign up for stamps.com no risk my promo
code yang you get a special offer that
includes a four week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts
four weeks could take you through the
holiday season look at that just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the home page
type in yang that's stamps.com and yang
i
literally did this yesterday because i
was returning a package and
it was super simple i went to the
website stamps.com i literally typed in
yang
i picked out the weight of my package
bought it printed it out
done it is simple it is easy and
thinking about trying to go to the post
office in kovaid and during the holidays
forget it so stamps.com go to the top
right
enter yang never go to the post office
again
[Applause]
[Music]
it didn't take long for you to uh to get
launched into the
national uh spotlight uh
during the 2016 bernie sanders one
uh revolution part one uh so you end up
like
a pretty big part in that race uh i i
would love to hear from your perspective
because at that time andrew yang was
uh just clicking on uh the tv like
everyone else and i watch in and you
know um
but you were getting uh uh you know a
participant's
perspective on the 2016 race uh
when did you realize uh
just how well bernie was going to
perform in 2016 and that he was going to
contend
i would have to say for all of the
traveling that i did
the pulse on the ground it was palpable
and i'm sure you've kind of picked that
up from watching it on tv but i mean
when i tell you
absolutely palpable that was my first
sign that oh
my god the people that were coming
across at these rallies across the
country
are really feeling something and i'm
using the word feel
deliberately it it wasn't in their head
it was really in their heart and they
latched on to senator
bernie sanders in the same for the same
reason why i did which is his
authenticity
his transparency uh the fact that he was
not afraid
to make the argument to make the case
that government and the leaders of this
government
particularly on the federal level have
failed the poor the working poor and the
very
middle class in this country you had
that kind of conversation
saying to the american people you
deserve better than what you are getting
and i'll tell you i do the thing that
really attracted me to the center you
talk about being a little selfish here
for me maybe it was selfish as well you
know growing up as the oldest of seven
children and having my mother die really
young my mother died when she was 42
years old
and i was in my 20s when she died and
all of my siblings so i'm in my 20s and
we're all two years apart my baby sister
was 12.
and i didn't quite know i didn't know
what the hell i was going to do was not
my my family's very working was working
poor
and i was at a community college the
very community college that i ended up
having a tenure track professorship at
but i was a student there
and thinking my god how am i going to go
on because my mother had no money she
had no life insurance policy
and she had absolutely nothing i did not
know how i was going to go on but i
really used that pain to catapult me
and so i graduated from that community
college i matriculated to a four-year
university i
earned two degrees there and then i
started to dabble into a phd
before politics kind of kind of got me
but i say that to say
what what what most drew me to
the senator was his righteous
indignation and two topics really hit
home for me one was medicare for all
which i'm
sure that doesn't come as any surprise
to you and the second was
higher education to make to make sure
that that
people that mothers and fathers and
and custodial parents you name it
college for all
because i'm a first generation college
graduate and i know how important that
was
to help me i mean it was it didn't solve
all of my problems
but it definitely helped me to be able
to lift my family out of poverty
and then when my son became a second
generation college graduate
that meant more to me than even the
degrees that i have right now andrew so
those were the
two beautiful two things that really
drew me to the senator so
in 2016 even though the media didn't
quite get it
if you were on the ground with us you
felt it i vividly remember
watching a bernie sanders speech
relatively early in that race
and i agreed with every word he said i
was like this guy just spoke
the absolute truth and i was like
that was like like i was like we need
more of this like this is what we need
um and then you had on the other side
hillary clinton
um who i'd say i was i was
fine with but i didn't have that much
enthusiasm for
uh and so for me it was a relatively
straightforward it's like yeah i'm going
to
um support bernie and then the fact of
course you know andrean's support was
you know like not that significant a
thing in 16.
um and then uh
and then his mistreatment at the hands
of the media and the dnc just like uh
like um made me even more fired up
uh where you talk about it's like while
the media didn't get it or what not it
seemed pretty clear to me that the media
was trying to
minimize the level of bernie sanders
support where a lot of the coverage was
like and he can't win
and like that this person you know it's
like well this is interesting it's like
oh surprising how many people are for
this guy and i was like have you
actually heard the guy
speak and it seemed very clear um
certainly after the fact even that the
dnc kneecapped him and did him dirty
uh you know that i think on the merits
if bernie had been just allowed to
compete freely against hillary clinton i
think there's a great chance he would
have won
that race the media wasn't trying to put
his thumb on the scale
um against him if the dnc rules and the
super delegates weren't against him i
think there's a great chance he would
have been the nominee in 16
and i think if he'd been the nominee he
would have beaten trump well you know i
agree with that
amen is what amen to everything that you
said
and it really stoked for the berniecrats
people who
believed in the senator from the
beginning resentment
with the dnc and you saw that play out
and you still see remnants of that
i think the party has a long way to go
to heal and to heal you have to admit
when you are wrong and that still has
not happened but i totally agree with
you we will be talking to
president bernard sanders right now
instead of having to deal with instead
of having to deal with the terror that
we have right now
yeah and i agree with you there's never
really a reckoning in the dnc where
there's never like a maya culpa like wow
we
uh screwed that one up on an epic scale
um though there was massive turnover at
the dnc
where when people are mad at the dnc and
you probably know this you go there like
it's probably like none of the same
people
anymore but none of them were our people
either so it was just i think they just
replaced people with the same types of
people
neoliberal yeah you would know better
than i do on that side i'm a member of
the dnc too by the way
yang i am a member of the dnc from the
great state of ohio even though
some people might not necessarily know
that because i definitely
am critical of the dnc because i do
understand what many of them don't
understand is that what drew
people to senator sanders was not an
affinity for
a party it was what he was standing for
and if the democratic party wants to
have a bigger tent and have the ability
to win
offices from the local level all the way
up to the federal level
they have to recognize that that new
majority
that it will take for democrats to win
are not necessarily all
die-hards they are they believe in a
value proposition
and not necessarily loyalty to a party
and especially young people yang i'm
sure you've saw that and heard that
on the trail yeah i appreciate the folks
who've been
doing the work in local democratic
circles and and party politics for a
long time but i also think there should
be an openness to
where the people are heading and so
it seems like there's been a kind of
preconception in a number of cycles it's
like well of course it's going to be
hillary of course it's going to be this
and it's like well
no one's voted yet you want to see what
the what the people think isn't that
what we're all about
and certainly that played out very very
forcefully in 2016
and then you were obviously
his national co-chair in 2020
this race from i'd be curious from your
perspective uh what happened with this
race
um where
certainly i was part of the race uh you
know i don't think i had much to do
but much to do with um with some of like
the
uh the state wins and losses uh down the
stretch since it it seems like a lot of
it came down to south carolina and some
other places
um so if you remember the dnc then you
remember when pete
butterjudge ran for head of the dnc oh
yeah
i was supporting ellison at the time
congressman ellison was my candidate
yeah so when you saw you probably saw
pete speak
uh to the dnc at various times like was
there an inkling then it's like
this guy this guy's gonna run for
president in a hot minute
whereas any sense of that i heard those
those rum rumblings i mean for me i
didn't i didn't give it a thought i mean
i was laser focused on congressman keith
ellison but
now that i think back on it yeah i do
remember people saying
saying that he had that that that itch
so to speak yeah so
i wasn't surprised to see him run
um so the bernie 2020 campaign um there
was a period when
i thought bernie was going to win the
race um i think a lot of people did
you know like that when you looked at it
i mean
um bernie and pete were essentially the
co-winners coming out of iowa depending
upon how you look at it
um and then everything you know how i
look at it
we won iowa go ahead go ahead yeah well
for what it's worth for what it's worth
i tweeted the same nina i was like i
think bernie won iowa
let's go on to the next one you know
it's just because i thought it's like
well the man
you know man got more votes um that's it
the popular seat but you see how he
changed the rules
and you know open up pandora's box on
that see the popular vote
that doesn't didn't count for our
campaign at the time
they changed the rules on us in iowa but
uh we went on to make history we won the
first three contests
technically you know i mean that was a
big deal
and we still were ripped off by the
media
there was a head of steam so you you
went to iowa and i said as much when new
hampshire which people expected but it
was still a
a romper and then coming out of nevada
it was like bernie i you know and i was
quoted as saying it too i was like it's
a great chance bernie like runs the
table here
um so tell me about those days because
i've been now part of my own campaign
and you have like a head of steam
momentum
when things don't go well uh it you feel
like
you're on like this is what i felt like
oh this first time i've described it
this way let's see if it works
um so you you know those medieval movies
when they're like a bunch of people on
on horse like you know like a braveheart
type charge or like this
that's what it felt like when you're on
like the campaign trail you're like
riding and you know
doing rallies and all these people
volunteering for it for your campaign
and energizing you
and then when things go poorly um in a
race it feels like that scene in that
movie when like
the horses fall like there's like this
you know uh pit and then like the horse
is going
oh and then like you're all like sort of
um on the ground and everyone's
scrambling around
and like you know people are um like uh
getting
stabbed right left at least that's the
way the movie goes
uh so so that that's where things go
poorly
um but when things are going well it
feels like
you're never gonna lose it feels like
we've got the wind at our back
and everything's going our way and uh we
will not be denied i'd love to hear
what it was like from your perspective
uh like heading in and out of iowa in
the early states
it's almost an indescribable feeling
especially since i was with the senator
in 2016
and just to see that kind of momentum i
felt as though
the seeds we planted as i reflected
state by state i i felt like the seeds
we planted in 2016 were bearing fruit
in 2020 that's how it felt and
it just it was it's like a snowball
rolling down a mountain right
you're picking up that picking up that
that pace and rolling fast and building
building building
and by the time we got to nevada and
when those results came
in because i was the one in nevada and i
stayed there to give the
you know the speech to the to our
supporters
in person there on the senator's behalf
and i mean
it was smoking you hear me because what
nevada proved because remember
yang all the naysayers said oh yeah iowa
is white
totally disregarding the black people
and other people of color that live in
that state
but i digress new hampshire is white
so again totally bernie's neighboring
state right so they'd be like
oh nothing nothing it didn't mean
anything
you know but when we got to nevada baby
they couldn't deny it they couldn't deny
the diversity
and he won especially young people
you know the african-american community
our hispanic community he won
communities of color in nevada along
with our white
sisters and brothers so he couldn't be
denied and to me i think
that is the moment when the neoliberal
when the power structure of the
democratic party decided
we got to put a stop to this i really do
believe that and
south carolina did us in and
it wasn't enough time between south
carolina and the other states
for us to re to regroup i have never
seen
an endorsement have an impact like jim
clyburn coming out for joe biden in
south carolina that was
unbelievable it was like someone had
just taken
like a um like a
pin out of a dyke or a dam or something
like that where all of a sudden
clyburn was like i'm for joe and all of
a sudden whoosh like
this freaking tide of voters in south
carolina followed his lead
i genuinely think that that one
endorsement changed the course of the
nomination
and the race entirely the course of
history really
you you feel that way imagine how we
felt when i tell you we worked
extraordinarily hard in that state we
worked harder in that state than the
biden campaign i know that unequivocally
we were in that state early we didn't
take anything for granted
we had people coming in and out of that
state our national surrogates people who
you and i both admire
like dr cornell west made several trips
to that state
brother you know delete the weapon
himself danny glover who was beloved
across
generations he even drove yank
brother danny glover drove from one end
of south carolina to the
other drove himself he would be in that
state sometimes when even i wasn't
i adopted that state even though i
traveled all over the country
i visited south carolina more than any
other
state going to all kinds of events
bringing people in susan sarandon
tim robbins i mean you name it in and
out
all age groups phillip agnew from the
dream defenders who i know you know i
mean just from
from millennials to boomers to gen x's
you name it
we put so much effort and that south
carolina team worked so
hard and we knew our backs were against
the wall
so although we it didn't have the
outcome that we wanted
we worked and didn't take it for granted
and you're absolutely right when
congressman clyburn came up in there
it totally turned that entire thing
around you know vice president biden up
until that point had never won the
primary and all the times he had run for
president until
that particular moment and then the
coalescing
of everybody else on that ticket you
might not necessarily agree with me but
when you got the number two candidate in
the race so far
drop out and endorse you know vice
president biden you got
senator klobuchar did the same thing
others did
hey that was it that was all she wrote
and
then covet hit two so you got all of
that
plus covet bam
end of our end of our our run
uh i feel your pain um
i was trying to describe that sort of
the charge like the high of feeling like
you're gonna
win um and then that dispiriting
uh uh
feeling that you can't describe too when
you realize you might not win or when
you realize like oh my gosh like as hard
as we fought
and scratched and clawed here in south
carolina to try and win every vote
uh you know it it may not go our way uh
it's why we in some ways
uh do what we do where the only way you
can succeed
in this kind of politics and activism is
if you're putting your heart and soul
into it or else it's impossible that's
one thing that people don't
appreciate fully where they think it's
like oh you could be doing it for
um you know some kind of self-serving
reason it's like you try doing this for
any length of time
for any reason other than the fact that
you genuinely
are trying to um to
fulfill like a vision that someone else
has or you have or think you can improve
people's way of life because it's
uh and so you put your heart and soul
and energy into it and then when it
doesn't go your way it's
devastating it is so hard uh to just
like pick yourself up after that and be
like well you know that like especially
in your case because you'd been grinding
it out for years
five years when the senator created our
revolution as you know after 2016
and and i got the opportunity to run
that organization then he ran again so
yes
five years and five years i i i
physically touched down in almost 50
states
i think there are only three states that
i did not physically
go to over the last wow years
yeah i gave it my all yeah really we
know you did nina
i mean it's why you have so much uh
admiration among
so many of us is that we know you're a
warrior and that you've been
uh fighting the fight uh on the ground
in the air
on the airwaves like wherever it needs
to be fought like now
in your in your earbuds nina's got a
podcast that i'm gonna go on in a minute
um hello somebody is the podcast
hello somebody there we go
[Music]
[Applause]
i was not great in the kitchen uh where
i haven't been
i grew up on those stouffer's french
bread pizzas
like my my parents would just my parents
would just leave us alone in the house a
lot
and anytime we needed a meal we would
just take frozen meals
and heat them up and that that was our
food prep
as uh kids but frozen food's not that
awesome for you
health-wise if you just keep doing it
over and over again but who wants to go
through all of the pain
of actually getting ingredients and
preparing them and cooking them if you
do that more power to you
um but if your dream is the
simplicity of a frozen meal that
actually is not
frozen then we have freshly for you
it's amazing they deliver a non-frozen
meal you can just heat up it's like the
simplicity of frozen food
with the health benefits of a freshly
prepared meal
that's been prepared by someone that's
not you freshly is offering
our listeners 40 off their first two
orders at freshly.com
yang that's freshly.com yang i just love
the variety frankly
um and it's delicious so again we're
offering you guys
all of our listeners 40 off for your
first two orders
at freshly.com yang
[Music]
[Applause]
so covet is hit and then the entire
world has changed
uh you know joe's the nominee um
one of the reasons by the time we're
having this conversation he
or this thing gets released like he may
even be
um the president-elect i mean uh you
know
we'll see i i believe that he will be
um the thing i'm most eager to talk to
you about is what the future
of the democratic party looks like or
politics if it's not within the
democratic party
uh because you and i were sharing
frustration over the fact that we
haven't passed a covid relief bill
i'm very very frustrated i think that
it's devastating for
millions of american families they
deserve better
there is no excuse to
before stalling aid for any kind of
uh political purpose um if we don't get
aid
across the finish line soon like we
might be waiting until 2021
uh it the last time anyone got any help
was april even that wasn't sufficient
um so my frustration with with the
democratic party is
uh quite high on that front um and on
other fronts
uh you know some of them that we we
described here
um we do have something of uh duopoly
going
um and the republican party
is uh is the party of trump
right now um so to me like there there's
no meaningful
choice where to be no uh
like i've obviously been campaigning for
um for joe and kamala
but i'm really interested to hear what
you forecast
both as like the future we want to see
and you were one of the people that said
like i think the democratic party's
worth fighting for
though that was a number of years ago
and you know number of uh i can't
count campaign campaigns ago
i'm starting to feel believe it believe
that less so
andrew to be honest with you um to your
point
peop flesh and blood it's not widgets
and
one of my greatest honors was serving on
the local level i know all the oxygen
and
goes to the shiny objects up in the
congress
but to really know when you meet your
constituents in the grocery store or at
funerals or when you're at a doctor's
appointment and they're pouring out
their heart about their challenges
somehow some people in that congress
have totally
lost track of the flesh and blood
the everyday people that either
suffer or whose suffering is ameliorated
because of some actions that they take
and it is a disgrace it is
immoral in my book what is going on
right now
on both sides you know i'm not letting
any of them off the hook when we have so
many
of our sisters and brothers yeah
absolutely suffering it is unacceptable
to let politics get in the way of the
politics and i say it that way
because politics can be used as a tool
for good
now we don't see much of that these days
but it can
so when people say politics got in the
way i questioned what type of politics
got in the way
but now they're letting the politics get
in the way of the politics
and it's don't give trump a win because
i believe that's what's going through
their head
don't don't give him a win at all costs
and so
the people who are suffering our
collateral damage
and you tell me how you feel that's how
i feel and that right there
is wrong as hell and wrong as heaven
pick your choice hell or heaven but it's
wrong
yeah i i would uh approach this
negotiation nina where it's like when
push comes to shove
i'm just gonna try and get the people
what they need uh in a time frame that
might actually
save lives alleviate suffering keep
roofs over people's heads
uh you know and i'm gonna push for the
best bargain i can with the constraint
that i'm [ __ ] going to deliver to my
people like
in a reasonable time frame you know so
like that that to me would be the
priority especially in this case where
like look if you don't get everything
you want like you can always go back and
try again
uh like in the new year there's gonna be
like another set of people so it lends
weight to your feeling that there are
there there's like a political
calculation going on here
uh where you don't want to give trump
the win
um it's certainly not the way i'd
approach it like i i feel like
not enough attention isn't paid to this
i don't understand it i've
and i've talked to at least a couple of
members of congress roh who whom you're
friends with i'm sure from the campaign
because
at least he said take the deal you know
take the deal
like that's really the takeaway just
take take the [ __ ] deal
um so uh was row another
national co-chair he was oh my god
yang i was so blessed so it was
congressman ro khanna
uh mayor carmen yulin cruz from puerto
rico
and the ice cream man himself ben cohen
of uh one of the founders of ben and
jerry's it was jerry's of course
yes highest honor one of the highest
honors of my life to serve
with them and for them to make me the
first among equals
i mean i i would do this all over again
if they would be co-chairs with me they
they are
absolutely the best one of the the
conversations i had recently nina that
um you might find interesting it's
actually i think very very good listen
um i sat with justin amash who
um you know we may differ with
politically in many many respects but he
actually was digging into the dynamics
and the mechanics in the process
and he what he suggested was like look
if you're the average member of congress
and you're if you're in the minority
party you're not seeing any of it and
even if you're in the majority party
you're not seeing a whole heck of a lot
of it it's like the leadership's working
it out
uh and and you're like several rungs
away
from the negotiations just kind of
waiting for a bill to come in
um and then you're not gonna have much
time to review the bill
uh and you're gonna be asked to just
sort of give a thumbs up or thumbs down
and the easiest thing you can do is just
sign off on it because there's not a
robust amendment process anymore like
there's not a whole lot going on
so even if you're in congress you're
essentially waiting for nancy to deliver
anything for you to look at
um and uh that that's the way
it's happening on the democratic side on
the republican side it would be you know
like you're waiting for mitch
or in this case uh steve mnuchin or
trump or whoever
um and it was a very bleak vision
frankly of the way these
deals are getting hammered down and the
way legislation is getting passed you
have more experience than i do where you
were a state legislator when i talked to
folks who were
from state legislatures they described
and this actually includes justin
because he was a state legislator in
michigan he was like it worked so much
better
at the state level than at the federal
level in his experience
yeah at least he has those two to
compare have not reached the federal
level
yet we'll see uh stay tuned
but no it just it doesn't make sense
analyze the problem what you just
described
is problematic and so my question would
be
why aren't the members some members are
like congressman rocanna but i'm talking
about the ones
if i were a member of congress i would
be stepping on desks on heads
crime bloody murder because my people
are suffering because y'all want to play
games
they don't have time to weight game see
that's all i have i don't have patience
or toddler
some at some some and some at some level
we got to draw the line and this is one
of them
a worldwide pandemic can't get these
folks to move
the suffering of millions of people
can't get them to move
it makes no sense to me democrats and
republicans both
it's part this is a problem
dysfunctional
government dysfunctional government um
the detachment of our leaders from the
day-to-day lived experience of the vast
majority of their constituents
uh that's something that
no i i think is killing us
it's corruptive in various ways so one
thing i'm for i'd be curious what you
think of this and that this i don't know
um i haven't heard you talk about it but
i'm for term limits
uh in part for some of these reasons um
uh they could be on the longer side you
know i was proposing 12 years during the
the campaign so it's enough time for you
to settle in and get some stuff done
it's not like in and out but
um it would also prevent someone from
being there for
30 years and just kind of waiting their
turn
and the rest of it and one person who
helped convince me
of this uh approach is ro
actually i talked to rowan he's like
yeah there should be term
if i had to judge today's congress i
would say that but as somebody who
served in the legislature where there
are term limits i'm kind of torn and i'm
torn for this reason
unlike the city council you know the
local level i served
to me state level and the national level
to quote
the reverend dr martin luther king he
wasn't saying this in reference to
congress but i just want to use
longevity has its place
and sometimes you need people to need
to be in these seats more than just a
minute now you don't need them to be
there forever
but there's some institutional knowledge
that is wrapped up into being in a place
and if you're using that knowledge to
help
navigate politics on behalf of your
constituents it's a good thing
if you're there holding up stuff it's a
bad thing but the pot let me go back to
the
power is going to go somewhere so i
question
whether or not we want the power to be
in the hands of bureaucrats
or we want the power to be in the hands
of people who were
elected by the people as problematic as
that can be
what i've learned on the on the state
level is that
we pa this state passed term limits
because people were like throw out the
bombs they were upset they were mad
but a lot of the people who were in
charge of that campaign at the time
have had second thoughts because what
they have seen is that
nature abhors a vacuum and so that power
is going to go
somewhere you know where it goes it goes
with the on the bureaucratic side
how long are the term limits in ohio
eight years in both chambers
but what you can do is you can switch
chambers so in a way they found a
loophole
in the term limits but what it has done
is that the bureaucrats and the
lobbyists in our state
they have a lot of the power because
there's no limit
for their influence yeah i i think that
there is a legitimate concern
around uh like you said power just
flowing to uh lobbyists bureaucrats
unelected figures um i think if you do
term limits which i still do believe in
um you you need to make them long enough
so that
it's not just people coming in and out
and looking around trying to find the
bathroom while like
the lobbyists are pulling the strings
right
well they're pulling strings now so but
yeah
yeah so that so there there is a tension
there because there would be
the other thing i believe is that um
term limits make more sense at the
federal level the congressional level
than they do at the state level
um because i because i've heard what
you'd said at the state level
um it's a it's more of an issue and i
also think the detachment
issue is a bigger problem at the federal
level like if you go to dc and you're
hanging out there for
um you know uh 20 25 30 years like it's
hard to feel
like uh like that person that
is you know just trying to get by in
your community if you're like
hanging out in dc for that long and
we're making elected officials
celebrities without which i abhor
rock star hell no we need servant
leaders we don't need rock stars
in the congress and that is something
about our culture and social media and
how many clicks and how many followers
that has really just turned this thing
around that people want stars
instead of workhorses being able to
quantitate
or like have put a number on
people's following is dark
and evil it's terrible it's like you
just end up chasing
uh clicks and views and [ __ ]
uh you know it it's it's all a
distraction um but because you can count
it
it becomes this is actually a summary of
a lot of things that are wrong in
american life
it's like if you can count it then all
of a sudden you're like i can count this
like the most important things about
life that you can't count uh end up
falling by the wayside
true that it's so true well andrew yang
i don't know we didn't solve all the
problems of the world but i think we got
a little more understanding you asked me
to talk about what i where i think the
future holds
i do believe that the civil unrest that
we've been seeing
is going to continue no matter who wins
this country needs a real healing i
don't think we have the leadership in
either one of the camps to have the type
of moral
clarity and healing voice that is
necessary
and i compare that to it maybe this is
might not be a
fair comparison so i will admit that up
front
to what mr nelson mandela then president
nelson mandela was able to do
on the backdrop of an apartheid south
africa and he had such moral
you know not just that he was brilliant
not just that he was a revolutionary not
just that he went to prison
for almost 30 years for standing up for
black south
africans but that he had
this moral clarity and
essence about him that was able to pull
that nation even if it wasn't in the
it he pulled that nation together now
more work needs to be done in south
africa i'm not here to say that the
lives of black africanas
are where they should be because it is
absolutely not
yeah the truth and reconciliation like a
massive step forward i mean we could use
that
here in the u.s long time coming and so
that is one of my biggest fears
is that people especially people who are
totally anti-trump are going to be so
have such a sigh of relief that he's not
there should he lose
that that's going to be it that the
expectation of the
next administration is going to be very
low
and i'm worried about that this is the
big danger
nina is that everyone's like okay we got
rid of trump it was all trump's fault
uh now normalcy can return meanwhile
people's way of life will still be
disintegrating people will still be
losing trust and faith in government
and you just be like no look i'm sane
i'm rational i'm well intended i'm
competent like that should be enough
everyone calm down
and it's like no you're missing the
point like you're missing the point that
millions of us have been left behind uh
millions of us have been ignored
it's getting worse for millions of us
you know our way of life is
deteriorating
and the big danger is that the forces
that gave rise to donald trump are not
going away i mean trump was sort of a
singular figure
um but there is going to be a successor
to trump
and this populist energy is going to
keep on rising on both sides
because you have such low trust and
faith in our institutions
who have done nothing to to demonstrate
that they deserve our faith and
confidence like
you know like a lot of the time and my
great fear nina
is that the democratic party is going to
be the last people standing saying
believe in institutions believe in
institutions
while the crowds just keep getting
bigger and bigger being like why on
earth would we be listening to you
um and this is a critical weakness of
the democratic party is that they
actually
are uh um
kind of blinded um to the failings
of their own institution and the and the
institutions that they represent and
embody
like that they and you can see it in the
fact that they
um like when someone calls out their
failures like you know like that they
just look up
at you like you're ignorant or you don't
understand how the world works or
whatever
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know meanwhile it's
like look you've been failing us for
years
like where are the consequences to that
uh you know
and and and one of the reasons why like
i love what
you and bernie said for is like you're
trying to do it the good way
it's like look here you're like let's
just get more votes you know like
there there are many nastier ways that
that things are going to be um
challenging that these institutions and
the these leaders
uh and and they're they're they're just
not
uh many of them don't see it um i'm
hopeful that they'll go
big enough and dig deep enough where
they can actually start solving some of
the real problems that are
experienced by people and restore that
trust and confidence it's a very tall
order and it's something we have not
seen
uh it would require something new it
would require something new
um out of people and it sounds like
you're looking at it saying look andrew
there's not much reason for me to expect
something new
no it's not i'm really counting on this
uprising this awakening that we're
having and groups like roots action
and our revolution and progressive
democrats of america even
dfa the uh or the democratic socialists
of
america uh i those types of groups and
then
black lives matter and other groups that
i have not
named that that bubbling in the streets
is going to continue
i do not want the sleeping giants
andrew to ever go back to sleep i want
them to stay awake
i want them to continue to fight for
what is just for what is right
and what for what is good to not allow a
biden harris administration to have a
honeymoon
because the pandemic just revealed what
was already there and like you just said
that
populist energy on the trump side is
going to go somewhere
and it's going to go to somebody that's
a little more savvy than
uh president donald j you you could have
someone
both malignant and competent you know
what i mean like not not just like
like the kind of buffoonery uh of
uh it would be worth trump it would be
worse so it will behoove
the democratic party to get a clue and
to get a clue
quickly and to provide a to have a
vision that provides provision
for the people and that's why i love
about your universe universal basic
income i mean you came in with some
ideas that were and i got to tell you to
my son i forgot to tell him
we were interviewing maybe when i
interviewed you for my show because he
he he liked you too so um
yeah you came in with some really strong
ideas and i think
um between your campaign and our
campaign we were quite
a force in awakening the sleeping giants
and getting people to dream another
dream
a bigger dream to see the world through
new eyes or through a different lens of
what is possible that's what our
campaign we've been accepting too little
and asking for too little in many
respects
for too long that's right everyday
people so
andrew listen i'm gonna keep pushing out
there raising hell i consider myself a
hell raising humanitarian whether people
like it or not
and let's see what happens well nina
you're not going anywhere we definitely
need you
uh and um we need to
either get the democratic party to uh to
find itself or present something
different
but you're going to be a huge part of
either one of those and i
appreciate the hell out of you for it
thank you for being here
well thank you and i appreciate the hell
out of you too this has been
beautiful thank you for listening in i
hope you enjoyed this conversation if
you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]